[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv et 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 3 janvier comme
pour une bonne partie de la france la
tempête
eleanor a également sévi dans les
yvelines repassée en vigilance jaune et
des rafales qui ont causé quelques
dégâts et nécessité l'intervention des
pompiers
reportage à suivre cet effectif depuis
le 1er janvier 11 vaccins sont désormais
obligatoire pour les enfants contre 3
auparavant
à quelles urgences sanitaires
répond-t-il éléments de réponse avec
notre invité renault nadjani président
de l'union régionale des professionnels
de santé pharmaciens ile de france
enfin c'est une mode après lé fait
perdre les quelques kilos pris pendant
la période et à côté du sport les
régimes détox ont également le vent en
poupe
explications et idées de plats légers en
chronique dans cette édition
et puis nous recevons également dans ce
journal le nouveau que secrétaire
d'europe écologie les verts ile de
france il est yvelinois c'est david
jutier 4800 foyer yvelinois privés
d'électricité au petit matin la tempête
eleanor a également touché le territoire
les yvelines était en alerte orange aux
vents violents jusqu'à au jusqu'au début
de l'après midi et après de nombreux
incidents le plus souvent causés par des
chutes d'arbres plus de 160
interventions de pompiers ont été
nécessaires reportage de camille lambert
et patrick jacques de dixmude
depuis 3h ce matin les sapeurs pompiers
des yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre
la tempête et léa nord a frappé le
département plus 280 agents ont été
mobilisés pour sécuriser les zones à
risque on avait un arbre qui menaçait à
un poste de détente de gaz donc il a
fallu le couper de faire tomber
afin de sécuriser les abords pour pas
qu'ils tombent sur des passants ou sur
des véhicules à rambouillet on est les
douze personnel de la garde sont
mobilisés on a fait appel à quelques
personnels de repos afin de grossir les
rangs au total plus de 160 interventions
surtout dans le sud et l'ouest du
département
c'est ici au centre opérationnel
départemental d'incendié et de secours
que les quatre opérateurs coordonne les
événements le principal manche et du
dégagement en arbre ou de branches
d'arbres sur la voie publique
on a aussi des fils électriques tombés
sur la voie publique et après on a des
objets menaçant de tomber en ville ça
peut être des éléments de cheminées des
tuiles des choses comme ça
les sapeurs pompiers ont aussi travaillé
en partenariat avec d'autres services
par endroits la tempête à abîmer les
installations électriques à magny les
hameaux et nady c'est la police
municipale sont intervenus rapidement
vers 6h30
un arbre a chuté sur la voie publique en
entraînant avec lui un câble électrique
j'ai été moi déclenchée par par la
brigade de gendarmerie de magny les
hameaux
voilà vingtaine d'habitations peu près
touché par une coupure d'électricité qui
devrait également rétabli dans la
journée à la mi journée encore 480
foyers étaient privés d'électricité dans
les yvelines un retour complet à la
normale est prévu dans la soirée
mais la prudence reste de mise même si
la vigilance orange a été levée par
météo france dans le département à des
vents violents qui ont également
perturbé les transports le trafic de la
ligne e du transilien est interrompu
jusqu'à la fin de service ce soir à
cause d'un incident de caténaire avec
moi en plateau david jutier bonsoir un
soir vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition à rambouillet vous avez été
désigné en décembre cosecrétaire
d'europe écologie les verts
ile-de-france avec les abats l'âge avant
de parler de cette nouvelle édition on
parlait il ya un instant de la tempête
eleanor ces derniers mois ces phénomènes
météo dévastateurs sont sont récurrents
je pense aussi aux ouragans et irma et
et maria qui ont sévi aux antilles
françaises cela montre quoi finalement
que l'urgence est à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
bien sûr que ça doit être absolument une
priorité de toutes les politiques
publiques
on voit que le dérèglement climatique et
pas seulement le réchauffement augmente
la fréquence en tout cas d
des phénomènes destructeurs donc
évidemment il est plus temps de prendre
conscience qu'il est temps d'agir est
aujourd'hui malheureusement tous les
accords qui ont été passés ne sont pas
mis en oeuvre avec le niveau d'ambition
qu'il devrait donc évidemment nous
appelons à ce que les politiques
actuellement prennent toute la mesure de
ce phénomène qui va aller en s'aggravant
encore et qui va toucher surtout les
plus les plus démunis et c'est ça qui
est extrêmement injuste et sur ses
premiers mois est justement la
présidence emmanuel macron vous trouvez
que le gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
la nomination de nicolas hulot par
exemple n'est-elle pas un bon signal
c'était que c'était un bon signal mais
nicolas hulot tout seul
esseulé dans un gouvernement qui est mal
éclairé par de l'écologie et de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique sa
priorité
et puis évidemment c'est très
insuffisant alors vous avez été désigné
je les dis qu'au secrétaire d'europe
écologie les verts ile-de-france à
c'était en décembre comment comment vous
aborder cette nouvelle mandature
finalement on est aujourd'hui fin 2017
début 2018 à la fin d'un cycle pour les
écologistes cirque avait commencé avec
la création d'europe écologie les verts
en fin d année 2010 2009 2010 qui avait
été le début d'un formidable mouvement
d'espoir d'engouement de renouvellement
aujourd'hui cet élan est un petit peu
retombée on a vu qu'on a eu un turnover
chez nous extrêmement important des
personnes qui sont venues qui sont
impliqués puis qui sont repartis souvent
pour continuer à travailler à l'écologie
dans le monde associatif et donc nous
les écologistes qui sommes engagés en
politique parce que je pense
profondément qu'on ne changera vraiment
notre société et on ne prépare
réellement l'avenir que si on investit
le champ politique nous avons une
mission celle de regrouper à nouveau
toute la famille écologiste toute cette
nébuleuse dont on parle parfois de
personnes qui sont de bonne volonté et
pour venir former un grand mouvement de
l'écologie politique
on se donne un an et à la fin de l'année
2018 nous allons tenir des assises de
l'écologie politique et fonder un
nouveau mouvement pour repartir sur un
cycle qui on l'espère sera au moins
aussi enthousiasmant que le début du
cycle précédent et qui en plus durera et
il fondera un mouvement de grande
ampleur
est ce que cette refondation à peu près
aussi avec un autre yvelinois je pense à
benoît hamon qui a rejoint enfin qui a
créé même au sein du conseil régional un
groupe avec d'autres écologistes un
groupe finalement nyon de écologique et
sociale est ce que ça peut passer par
aussi un travail benoît hamon ça passera
par un travail avec l'ensemble des
forces de progrès des forces écologistes
des forces social en france aujourd'hui
évidemment des mouvements politiques
vous citiez celui de benoît hamon vous
auriez pu citer celui de jean luc
mélenchon de la france insoumise
vous auriez pu citer également des
mouvements syndicaux sociaux des
mouvements environnementalistes
il faut unir toutes ses forces final il
faut en tout cas la grande question
qu'on va poser à toutes ces personnes là
qui partagent les mêmes idées les mêmes
valeurs que nous c'est quel mouvement de
l'écologie politique voulez vous
construire avec nous demain lesquels
participation voulez-vous y amener y
apporter pour que le mouvement de
l'écologie politique que l'on va
construire à la fin de l'année 2018 et
tout le processus va s'étaler du
processus de construction sur 2018
puisse permettre à tout le monde de
se reconnaître de se retrouver et de
travailler dans le même sens
dernière question je vais vous demander
d'aller assez vite c'est un sujet très
épineux mais c'est là celui de la ligne
18 en ile de france vous est fixé comme
objectif de lutter contre plusieurs
projets dont fait partie cette ligne 18
qui pourrait nuire selon vos dires donc
au haut plateau de saclay à ce
territoire agricole quel plateau de
saclay on pense à se transforme en
aérien qui doit passer de 13 km qui doit
passer sur le plateau de saclay comment
s'y opposer à ce genre de dossier
ce type de dossier il risque simplement
de s'effondrer tout seul devant son
manque de pertinence et son coût
exorbitant
on a vu que line 18 allée d'or s'est
déjà remise en question tout comme à mon
avis le grand projet inutile sur le sur
gonesse sur les terres fertiles de
gonesse qui s'appelle europa city qu'à
un grand projet de centre commercial et
ludique à plusieurs milliards d'euros
risquent également de tomber tout seul
devant son sa propre inanité la ligne 18
c'est pas une ligne de transport c'est
juste un moyen d'urbaniser à nouveau
tout un pan de l'ile-de-france qui est
aujourd'hui une zone agricole et nous
avons besoin d'agriculture de proximité
en ile de france
merci david jutier d'avoir été avec nous
à cause des verts et d'europe écologie
les verts en ile de france écologie
toujours avec ce projet qui pourrait
vous intéresser c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour l' usine de biométhanisation
de thoiry elle utilisera les matières
organiques pour produire du biogaz
l'ouverture du site est prévue en
février à mars prochain et un
partenariat vient d'être noué entre grdf
et la chambre d'agriculture
d'ile-de-france est les précisions de
mélanie poker elle est pour l'instant la
seule dans les yvelines
la première usine de biométhanisation
est à thoiry mais elle pourrait bientôt
avoir des petites soeurs grdf et la
chambre d'agriculture d'île de france
viennent de signer un partenariat
alors cette convention va permettre
d'accompagner devait déjà de structurer
une filière avec un homme différent
nombre d'acteurs d'opérateurs sur le
sujet la méthanisation depuis les
exploitants agricoles à des porteurs de
projets mais aussi développer de
nouveaux projets faire émerger de
nouveaux projets donc ça va être à la
fois de la pédagogie
l'accompagnement de porteurs de projets
jusqu'à la mise en relation et les
porteurs de projets entre
cette usine produira du gaz vers d'ici
la fin du premier trimestre 2010 8 une
énergie possible grâce aux fumées
animale du zoo mais aussi les déchets
des exploitations agricoles alentours la
production de gaz et récupérer elle est
purifiée par l'équipe manquait juste
derrière moi pour être injectée dans le
réseau de gaz grdf et le fumier lui du
fait du temps de séjour de 21 jours donc
dans ce digesteur à être digérée par les
bactéries et ben le fumier et les
déchets verts et les fruits et légumes
invendus et cetera tout ça ça forme un
digestat c'est comme du compost c'est
très qualitatif et ça fait un engrais
écologique pour les cultures agricoles
d'un point de vue technique ce gaz
naturel renouvelable est totalement
assimilable au gaz naturel qui est
derrière et zoé d'ailleurs quand
injecteurs à ce gaz renouvelables
il sera associé de garantie d'origine un
petit marqueur qui fera en sorte de
d'identifier qu'il s'agit bien d'un gaz
renouvelables et non pas d'un gars
fossiles près de 2000 foyers sur huit
communes seront ainsi alimenter grdf
souhaite atteindre 30 % de gaz vers dans
ses réseaux français d'ici 2030
c'est l'une des premières grandes
mesures prises par agnès buzyn depuis sa
nomination comme ministre des
solidarités de la santé 11 vaccins sont
désormais obligatoire pour les enfants
et depuis 1er janvier contre trois
jusque alors bonsoir nonne hadj ali
bonsoir vous êtes pharmacien rambouillet
vous êtes le président du syndicat des
pharmaciens des yvelines également
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé pharmaciens
d'ile-de-france ont ce vaccin
obligatoire contre 3 avant trois qui
étaient réunis dans le dtp donc pour
différer tétanos poliomyélite
qu'est-ce qui s'ajoute finalement à ceux
des tpc la c3 vaccin va écouter les
vaccins obligatoires c'était la
coqueluche la diphtérie les mym au fil
us la pole du mali telle tête à nos cinq
ans fait donc y en avait en fait 5 et y
en a six autres qui était dit
recommander très bien en fait
recommander ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut une couverture vaccinale
pour essayer de diminuer une maladie
c'est quand même une invention
extraordinaire le vaccin dans la mesure
où on peut
arrêter des maladies et dieu merci la
varicelle la variole par exemple
n'existe plus c'est le début de la
vaccination
eh bien ça a été une avancée
extraordinaire pour l'humanité je ne
comprend pas la polémique autour de la
vaccination et je trouve très
franchement que madame busin avec
parfaitement raison de rendre ces
vaccins l'a dit obligatoire parce que au
moins comme ça il y aura plus de
discussion polémique vous parlez d'une
polémique 41% des français estiment que
les vaccins ne sont pas sur ça c'était
d'après une enquête internationale menée
à l'automne 2016 pourtant vous le dites
c'est primordial alors les anti vaccins
disent que une protection maternelle est
suffisante mais le vaccin a joué un rôle
primordial
alors la protection maternelle
évidemment c'est nécessaire mais pour
tout le tout petit c'est à dire que
c'est la mère qui va donner ces
anticorps à l'enfant qui vient de naître
mais ça suffit pas le problème de la
vaccination c'est c'est que c'est un
acte collectif
il faut que qu'il y ait un maximum de
personnes qu'ils soient vaccinés
l' oms considère de l'ordre de 90 à 80
ms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ars entre 90 et 95% de taux de
vaccination de façon à pouvoir arrêter
une maladie arrêter une maladie à tous
ceux qui défendent une vie des
bisounours entre guillemets c'est
souvent des gens qui n'ont pas connu les
grandes maladies parce que les autres se
sont vaccinés parce que les yeux nation
précédente plomb faits et parce que
aujourd'hui on est autour plus du
nombrilisme l'individualisme que de
l'action collective
or la vaccination protège les plus
faibles protège ceux qui sont
immunodéprimés protège les petits
enfants la coqueluche on en a parlé
l'essentiel de la transmission de la
maladie au nouveau né qui peut être une
maladie mortelle pour le nouveau né
c'est l'entourage proche c'est la
fratrie c'est les parents c'est le grand
paris finalement ça nous protège nous
mêmes et aussi l'entourage
absolument et c'est ça la santé publique
c'est à dire comment on peut faire pour
pouvoir essayer d'éradiquer du rhône à
éradiquer un certain nombre
de maladie ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut plus vacciner parce que les petites
bêtes ils continuent à se multiplier dès
qu'elles trouveront le moindre espace
pour se développer donc il est important
d'insister sur le fait c'est leur rôle
d'ailleurs de tous les professionnels de
santé que d'accompagner la population
sur cet esprit collectif de combat
contre les maladies
j'invite d'ailleurs téléspectateurs à
regarder le site vaccination qui est un
fou de cette attirer service.fr qui va
s'afficher qui s'affiche actuellement
voilà où ils trouveront évidemment
toutes les informations nécessaires
c'est des médicaments qui sont
particulièrement bien contrôlé et je les
invite aussi à lire la tribune du monde
du 2 juin 2017 qui a été parfaitement
fait autour
le vaccin silence ou rumeur il faut
choisir et que la gogo thérapie et les
grandes discussions qui ne sont pas
fondées je pense que ça n'apporte que du
mal pour la population précise juste que
ces onze vaccins sont obligatoires et
indispensables en maintenant pour que
les enfants puissent être admis en
crèche ou à l'école dernière question on
va aller très vite il nous reste moins
d'une minute
là je parle je vous parle en tant que
pharmacien de pose la question aux
pharmaciens les stocks sont sont
suffisamment grands y aura pas de
pénurie de vaccins on entend souvent la
pénurie de vaccins est ce que les stocks
sont sont conséquents alors il y a eu de
la pénurie de vagues pénurie de vaccins
mais sur des valences courte période
mais les vaccins avec plusieurs valence
c'est à dire plusieurs maladies sont
toujours en tout cas aujourd'hui
parfaitement disponible et donc j'invite
vraiment l'ensemble des téléspectateurs
de se donner l'envié de donner leur vie
autour d'eux de se faire vacciner et
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran à merci
renaud nadja d'avoir été avec nous mais
président notamment du syndicat des
pharmaciens a dit
yvelines suite de notre fil rouge de la
semaine retour sur les principaux faits
de l'année 2010 est ce soir c'est une
spéciale rebondissements le mois les
mois de mai à août ont réservé leur lot
de nouveautés en politique mais aussi en
sports récit est des événements nicolas
landry nicolas kirillovitch et les âges
un véritable basculement dans la vie
politique française
emmanuel macron devient le 7 mai 2010
est président de la république
vainqueur avec son mouvement en marche
et avec la volonté de bousculer le
clivage classique entre la droite et la
gauche
malgré une abstention record pour une
présidentielle
il est élu avec 66% des suffrages face à
marine le pen
une victoire retentissante jusqu'à
versailles avec les marcheurs illinois
est ce qu a réalisé emmanuel macron
c'est justement de papeterie français de
croire en eux et de re croire dans cette
belle dame qui est la cinquième
république et d'aller à la soupe
l'évolution démocratique versailles
théâtre diplomatique aussi en 2010 est
le président le plus jeune de la vème
république a choisi le château pour
recevoir le président russe vladimir
poutine et tenter de relancer les
relations franco russes sur de nouvelles
bases après la présidentielle les
élections législatives dans les yvelines
les républicains et le parti socialiste
ne résiste pas à la déferlante bastion
de la droite depuis 1993 les yvelines
bascule en faveur des marcheurs
ces néophytes de la politique rafle 11
sièges sur 12
je pense que c'est aussi la confirmation
que le projet que nous portons le
produit que nous avons construit avec
les français est un projet qui
finalement rassure les français et
veulent qu'ils veulent le voir au moins
essayé pour les cinq ans qui viennent
nous on est clairement dans une période
là il faut refonder refonder la gauche
c'est d'ailleurs ce que benoît hamon a
commencé à dire et qui va faire dès le
1er juillet le milieu d'année est aussi
marquée par des révolutions sportive à
plaisir en valeur et rugbyman entre dans
une nouvelle dimension
les hommes de victor garrigues et
obtiennent enfin leur ticket en
nationale 3 après avoir lutté six ans en
prénationale donc je pense que ça
représente énormément pour le public
pour le club les anciens du club le tout
les dirigeants les bénévoles les petits
c'est vraiment une grande famille c'est
pour tout le monde voilà c'est pas que
nous c'est pas que les doux c'est
vraiment un club qui avait tout ce
moment là tout son sens l'air de son
côté le 15 plaisir waro monte en
fédérale 2 3 ans après avoir quitté
cette division le travail effectué toute
la saison pour nous avec frédéric jardin
les moyens en équipe première mais c'est
le résultat d'un travail sur deux années
du combat il y en a eu à voisins le
bretonneux
la commune a failli basculer du côté
obscur de la force rebelle et jedi se
sont opposées le temps d'un week-end au
gymnase des pyramides
une convention star wars organisé par
l'académie des sabres laser vie sinoise
quelques arrestations le côté obscur
illuminé par les clubbers et les dj au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant une
nuit la piste de cyclisme sur piste
s'est transformée en piste de danse
house electro techno avec des relais aux
platines entre plusieurs artistes sa
soirée
quitte à voir dans les clubs déjà et
puis je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de
de la techno être enfin innovation sur
les greens du golf national de
guyancourt l'open de france est entré en
2017 dans une nouvelle ère à un an de la
ryder cup
le groupe chinois achètent à permet au
tournoi de devenir l'une des
compétitions les plus attractives en
europe avec une notation de plus de 7
millions de dollars
un pactole est remporté par le
britannique tommy fleetwood après la fin
d'année une autre fête l'épiphanie se
déroule dimanche prochain avec la
traditionnelle galette des rois
rendez vous incontournable des gourmands
qui prend cette année des allures
solidaire à voisins le bretonneux la
boulangerie olivier roy d'or vend à ses
galettes au profit du secours populaire
un sujet de camille lambert et michael
et le mindoro moulage feuilletage et
crème d'amande la technique reste la
même mais cette année le pâtissier a
ajouté un ingrédient à sa recette la
solidarité dans cette boulangerie les
galettes des rois pour l'épiphanie
seront vendus au profit du secours
populaire
j'ai plein de clients qui font des
actions caritatives
un voisin bretonneux à magny les hameaux
à guyancourt à montigny est donc là
l'occasion n'a été donnée d'apporter ma
pierre à l'édifice avec des des fèves à
l'effigié du secours populaire pour
pouvoir faire des dons au secours
populaire pour pour aider les gens pour
chaque galette acheté un euro sera
reversé à l'association
c'est la première fois que l'artisan
boulanger participent à cette opération
son objectif est déjà bien établie gare
à la remise d'un chèque officielle à la
fin de l'opération sachant je me suis
engagé à ce que je ne leur verse pas
moins de 6000 euros
c'est comme d'habitude sont des galettes
à la crème d'amande des galettes aux
pommes des galettes bordelaise
des galettes chocolat voilà un classique
5 fait différente sont cachés dans les
galettes chacune d'elle représente une
action du secours populaire dans les
yvelines
trois boulangeries participe à la
galette solidaire jusqu'au 31 janvier
au total l'opération permettrait de
récolter près de 100000 euros et la voix
de ce sujet était signée aurélie rose
elle dimanche soir c'était le réveillon
de la saint sylvestre l'un des repas les
plus caloriques de l'année avec celui de
noël viennent s'ajouter à ça vous l'avez
vu dans le sujet précédent la galette
des rois en janvier et dès le début de
l'année à la détox autrement dit des
régimes pour nettoyer l'organisme sont
en vogue et pour en parler de ce
phénomène le spécialiste détox et
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 comment fait-on
nickel pour détoxifier son corps après
les excès des fêtes
alors l'idée la detox est simple notre
corps ne serait plus capable de gérer
les déchets qui se seraient accumulés
dans notre corps avec une alimentation
considéré comme trop polluante selon les
statistiques un français et prendrait
envoyés entre deux et trois kilos
pendant les fêtes
je vous rassure guère brillé ça peut
être beaucoup plus vrai certains pour
nettoyer son corps il faut donc bannir
les poissons comme le saumon
incontournable foie gras les repas à
base de viande ou encore les boissons
alcoolisées et se concentrer plutôt sur
des légumes comme nous l'expliquent la
coach sportive et diététicienne les
silos bras on écoute dans les légumes
on a des fibres et que les fibres
justement ont pour vertu d'accélérer
le système digestif et en plus c'est
satiété ce que les fibres avec l'eau
prennent du volume dans l'estomac et on
a on est plus vite rassasié et on
arrivera à tenir jusqu'à la fin de la
journée pour prendre un autre repas sans
fringale c'est quand même ce qu'on vise
juste après les fêtes
manger des légumes c'est bien mais il
faut aussi qu'une fois cuisiner ils nous
donnent envie de les déguster dans
l'assiette c'est le conseil de leslie
levrat objectif tenir sur la longueur
grégory il a dit hey tissier nous a
préparé le plat idéal pour récupérer
après les fêtes un riz blanc au jasmin
aux lentilles tagliatelles gingembre
champignons noirs piments verts et
carottes très élaboré très élaborés
effectivement tout cela associé à du
lait de coco un plat équilibré et
détoxifiant qui se prépare en seulement
à 15 minutes rapide facile parce que là
ce que je fais clairement un vous avez
vu c'est facile et puis donc les
carottes elles vont importer la couleur
la plus sympa du plat ou en opposition
avec le riz blanc et les lentilles
marrons et puis elles vont réveiller le
blanc du lait de coco qui va servir pour
la cuisine et les lentilles
donc ça a l'air plutôt pas mal et
combien de temps on doit s'imposer ce
régime d'ailleurs pour qu une détox
fonctionne bien il faut tenir au minimum
deux semaines selon les conseils des
diététiciens mais il n'est pas interdit
de continuer après la fin janvier
merci michael on va tâcher de s'y mettre
dès ce soir à ce régime détox merci
beaucoup et puis ce sont toujours les
vacances dernier sujet de ce journal les
contes de noël ont pris leurs quartiers
au petit moulin à des vaux de cernay
histoire autour des as galette et petit
pot de beurre par la conteuse caroline
julie embarquement pour ce voyage
féerique avec camille lambert et nicolas
landry ils ont donné une gueule
bien doré bien croustillantes ils lui
ont dit comme ça c'est un petit creux au
milieu de la forêt tu pourras toujours
te régaler en campagne c'est l'histoire
d'un joueur de violon partis au village
pour rentrer chez lui il doit passer par
une forêt un bois groupe d ennemi
inquiétant il avoué
il en était sûr ils entendaient est
brune branches cassées derrière lui de
bruit froissé je raconte les grandes
questions universelles et intemporelles
donc les peurs les joies les surprises
des impatiences et la vie de tous les
jours c'est la vie des hommes depuis des
milliers d'années finalement on compte
depuis toujours
au fur et à mesure des débats et des
mots en fait on apprend quantité de
choses voilà les comptes aide à grandir
à sourire
alors on apprend un voyage à travers
différentes histoires drôles ou
poétiques la féerie de noël aux perches
les petits comme chez les plus grands
d'âgés mais parce qu'elle a été
intéressant de savoir
j'ai un prêt plein jour enfin c'était
drôle et tout lorsque on parle du loup
justement à cet âge là ils ont souvent
un petit peu cette crainte du loup et le
fait qu' on désacralise un petit peu le
voilà le loup ça permet de rendre cette
peur un petit peu moins en moins
présente les enfants dès 4 ans sont
attendus pour venir rêver au petit
moulin des vaux de cernay
réservation obligatoire pour embarquer
avec caroline dans son monde enchanté
[Musique]
et la dernière séance pour ses contes de
noël c'est ce vendredi à 5 janvier à
14h30
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
reportages et replay a retrouvé comme
d'habitude sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]